this is a production of Cornell
University
okay wow thank you so much for coming
out today the I'm very excited to share
some of the research I've been doing
with broccoli I'm gonna be focusing on a
paper that Thomas and I published in
September although we're gonna delve
into some other broccoli research as
well along the way yeah the story about
my grandfather he was an agricultural
engineer and I was looking through some
older papers where he was studying
irrigation and cabbage and I came across
one which is kind of cool so I've got a
little bit of background I'd like to
share a crash course in broccoli
so broccoli is one of the most consumed
green vegetables in the United States
and it's a highly consumed vegetable
worldwide so I that doesn't mean french
fries or ketchup as vegetables in that
case so currently America produces about
a billion dollars of broccoli a year in
terms of farm gate value
unlike many agronomic crops like maize
or wheat improve breeding improve
broccoli varieties is pretty challenging
because we have this whole extra
dimension called horticultural quality
that we care about things like what's
the aesthetic value of a particular head
of broccoli what's the shape of the head
is the head uniform is it smooth
are the buds small those kinds of
questions and those traits tend to be
complex and by that I mean maybe mini
genes control that phenotype there may
be strong genotype by environment
effects for those traits and there also
may be epistatic interactions where
expression of one gene influences
expression of a different gene so
oftentimes
these what types of improvement efforts
are not straightforward from a
traditional breeding standpoint that the
the key goal of my work was put most
simply is to find regions in the
broccoli genome that are associated with
horticultural traits that we care about
I'll use the term QTL for quantitative
trait loci a lot when and by that I mean
genomic regions with a statistical
association with a particular phenotype
of interest so the long term goal of
this work is ultimately to develop
molecular markers that can be used to
expedite and improve broccoli breeding
efforts so breeding broccoli that's
locally adapted in general we care about
broccoli on the East Coast and
specifically New York so these are that
is one potential long-term outcome of
this work Thomas and I spent a lot of
time beforehand thinking about broccoli
discussing it all of the implications
and these are some of the goals we came
up with we wanted to understand how much
diversity there exists within broccoli
is it all one in the same what are the
ways that it's different or can be
different based on its different
genotypes what are the flaws and
horticultural quality that we see
secondly we know that we knew that we
needed to produce really good molecular
markers that cover the broccoli genome
these needed to be reproducible and
ideally could be shared with other
researchers working on this particular
crop we wanted to not just find QTL but
QTL models that best explained these
important horticultural quality traits
in under a complex control hypothesis
there's going to be probably many genes
interacting what's the most parsimonious
model we can get to explain that
variation that we see and then this is
such an exciting time to be in plant
science there's so many people working
on so many different questions people
that are studying other Brassica crops
that are not Rockley people that are
working with a rapid abscess which is in
the same family how can we leverage all
of that work and information and apply
it to our particular questions so those
are some ideas that we had going into
this work and I wanted something a
little weird and start with the results
so we looked at 25 horticultural traits
in broccoli and amongst those 25 traits
we found 56 QTL and we also flagged 10
kind of genomic regions that seemed to
be especially important for high quality
broccoli we were able to produce a
really nice genetic map from this
special mapping population which I'm
going to talk about the those markers
are reproducible and reusable for other
researchers it's an immortal mapping
population so you can save seed from
every every plant and it's genetically
identical to its parents those plants
are now available by our friends at the
USDA so someone else that wants to study
secondary plant metabolites for example
could use this set of markers we made
can the same plants and very quickly get
some nice results a kind of surprisingly
unanswered question is why does broccoli
plants make broccoli heads well we have
lots of little pieces of information but
we we ultimately don't
really know the best QTL model for the
broccoli heading phenotype that we
produce from this analysis explains
about 82 percent of the variance in a
plant's ability to form a broccoli head
which is exciting we identified a number
of candidate genes within these traits
it's important to note that this is
preliminary work we're not proving that
this gene is causal we're trying to make
a smaller haystack
for future work where someone could do a
knockout experiment and confirm that
that G gene is essential for the
phenotype so just very quick information
about broccoli it's in the breasts of
cassia family there are 4068
main species in brass acacia and a rabid
abscess is one of them so that's great
that it's relatively closely related so
a lot of the information from
Arabidopsis has the potential to be
applied to broccoli although there's a
big asterisk there there are three
diploid species and the Brassica genus
all of those species can form tetraploid
species by combining both of their
genomes which is pretty wild
if you're not familiar with that
phenomenon and Brassica oleracea itself
contains many familiar vegetables and
quite a few vegetables that would be
unfamiliar to most Americans
and it was domesticated from a wild
woody plant that sound into the
Mediterranean Basin and over thousands
of years humans have selected these wild
plants for many different horticultural
quality traits in the case of broccoli
larger stems and many more flower buds
so how did this domestication occur like
I mentioned those wild Oller Asya types
are found all throughout the
Mediterranean Basin there's quite a few
of them there on these small islands and
rocky cliffs from a Valu vien
perspective are our best guess about the
domestication of broccoli is that it
occurred in southern Italy and Sicily
there's many many many landrace types
that are still grown there to this day
those landraces have a very high amount
of genetic diversity compared to the
modern hybrids that we see now this is a
botanical illustration of broccoli from
the South 18th century as you can tell
it looks pretty wildly different than
the broccoli that we're familiar with to
this day and that's you know sort of a
snapshot of how the improvement
domestication and improvement had
transpired the word broccoli we first
see in this in a 17th century text
Ricola in Italian and that is unclear if
it means the mint the diminutive form of
a chute or possibly a small nail there's
an older Latin word brokest which means
to project so over the last 4,000 years
humans have made tremendous improvements
in broccoli I I think all brassicas are
beautiful but improvement I mean made
the plant more suitable for human use
so things from like breeding for a
larger head which translates to a higher
yield head characteristics a more convex
head shape with a smoother surface
flower buds smaller flower buds that are
very round they can be fit together in a
more compact manner to make a
more dense head certain things that may
not be familiar to a consumer of
broccoli like plant architecture traits
how far does the head protrude above the
leaf rosette for example has pretty big
consequence if you're trying to harvest
a thousand acres if you can just
directly cut it off versus dig it out of
the plant and believe it or not upstate
New York has a slightly different
climate than Sicily yet you it's still
possible to grow broccoli here and
that's largely a function of humans
breeding broccoli to be adapted to a
wider range of climates this is a
picture of two broccolis that I grew in
my field this summer on the left is a
Italian land race that is still grown in
Italy to this day and on the right is a
modern f1 hybrid broccoli so obviously
the most dramatic difference is one is
way bigger but additionally there's
smaller more uniform buds and this more
beautiful convex head shape that we
expect in broccoli Americans nowadays
eat about 10 pounds of broccoli a year
who has eaten broccoli in the last
months a lot of people we're in a safe
place
does anyone does anyone hate broccoli we
have won everyone's welcome here
so yeah before the 1950s broccoli was
basically an unheard-of crop it was
brought here by Italian immigrants in
the 20th century and you couldn't really
find it in grocery stores or markets and
over time consumers have gotten wise to
how great it is and consumption has
trended upwards since then the
traditional
model of broccoli production has
centered around Southern California and
Arizona and how this typically works in
order to ensure a year-round supply
production will be based in Southern
California and Arizona in the middle of
the winter and then production will
shift northwards along these valleys
along the coast which remain relatively
cool throughout the summer and then the
fall production will shift southward
note that this map was made in 2007 the
story has changed quite a bit since then
also know that to get broccoli to these
East Coast markets requires a lot of
time and fuel so by the time broccoli is
harvested in California and brought to
the East Coast and as in your
refrigerator it can be a week to two
weeks so the head has lost a lot of
nutritional value flavor there's a
really big carbon footprint associated
with shipping it across the country so
this begs the question why not grow it
on the East Coast well in 2010 Thomas
and others got together this really
wonderful project called Eastern
broccoli project which is a
collaboration of public and private
groups USDA universities seed breeding
companies to develop an eastern broccoli
industry the philosophy is a strong
broccoli industry in the eastern US for
result and a regional supply of a
popular healthy food for consumers lower
transportation costs for retailers and a
market for a high-value specialty crops
for farmers so the idea is this model
would kind of mirror that California
production model where production would
happen in southern Florida in the winter
and shift northward towards the summer
and then vice versa in the fall so the
numbers are actually looking really good
so this is some data that shows the
number of farms on the east growing
broccoli from 2012 to 2017 and every
state has had an increase in the number
of farms growing broccoli in New York
the number has increased from 290 to 535
so it's pretty pretty good news what's
the bottleneck why do you need an
eastern broccoli project so the truth of
the matter is when you grow California
varieties of rocket on the East Coast
they usually look terrible they were
bred in California for California
conditions they're not adapted to the
East Coast here we see a head of
broccoli a broccoli plant that is not
producing a head and will not produce a
head here's a broccoli plant that is
making something vaguely reminiscent of
a head but all broccoli is beautiful but
this one is let may be less beautiful
than others it has a very irregular head
surface there's these racks that
protrude through the head and the color
is this bizarre chartreuse color so a
food distributor would not buy this from
a farmer so it would be a direct loss
here's some other bad broccolis or as
Thomas likes to refer to them hashtag
broccoli fail so this has more of the
Brax very irregular bud size some you
have these fully mature buds and
immature buds kind of mixed together
here's a very asymmetrical head of
broccoli grown on the East Coast there's
this sepal defect here where the bud
isn't fully closed this is a very common
problem here's some heads that look
slightly better they have a
very lumpy irregular head surface which
is more than just cosmetic after your
overhead irrigation or a rain event the
head will not be able to shed that water
and it can cause rotting to form even
droplets of water that remain on the top
function is basically small magnifying
glasses focusing the Sun and can burn
the head so what is this heading
broccoli phenotype why is broccoli
peculiar amongst all of those other
Brassica oleracea vegetables this is
some scanning electron microscopy work
of a vegetative meristem early
reproductive meristem and then early
middle and late heading stages so what
broccoli does uniquely is it has a
developmental arrest at this early
heading stage followed by meristem
proliferation not unlike a broken copy
machine it just keeps making all of
these these floral primordia so this is
what sort of an up-close view of this
bad broccoli phenotype on the east coast
looks like so you have sort of a mixture
of these buds that were arrested at the
fully mature stage and arrested at the
early bud stage here's a more up-close
image of that phenomenon where some buds
were able to escape and others got held
back at an earlier stage so what are we
looking at here so this is a difference
an arrest stage what would you do if I
told you that this is the same variety
of Brassica oleracea well you'll have to
take my word for it it's a variety
called green harmony which is a tropical
cauliflower
that's very popular in Southeast Asia
and under
warmer Southeast Asian conditions you
get this cauliflower phenotype under
cooler conditions like New York it very
much produces a something we would refer
to as a head of broccoli right so this
is clearly an example of gene expression
under different temperature regimes and
we know that that sensitivity to heat
happens from the CTE stage that the
temperature conditions at that stage
will have major implications on the
ultimate heading phenotype there's a ton
of research that has studied this
question and we don't have time to get
into it Thomas and his guys student at
the time Deniz dewclaw did a really nice
work where they compared expression of
floral identity genes and Arabidopsis to
the broccoli heading model and what they
found is that the broccoli heading model
is just simply more complex if anyone
was lucky enough to see Chris piers talk
last thing he talked about Gino and
triplication there's tends to be more
copies of these homologous genes so we
can't simply rely on what we know about
a rabid OPS's to work in the context of
broccoli some other papers have come out
recently that are really really nice
here the authors are comparing
expression of this flowering locus see
gene which is sensitive to vernalization
under more warm and cold conditions and
comparing heat stress pardon me heat
susceptible and heat tolerant varieties
and they find evidence of differential
expression of this FLC gene another
paper came out and that shows curd
development in broccoli and they
identify the role of FLC 2 and F SC 3
within different
so there's there's sort of an
convergence on the role of FLC and this
broccoli heading phenotype but the the
story is not complete yet
so finally to the experiment so we were
able to use this really wonderful
mapping population that was made from a
cross between a Chinese kale and a
broccoli the broccoli makes a head of
broccoli the Chinese kale does not and
the offspring segregate for kind of the
degree of heading this as well as a lot
of other really cool horticultural
quality traits we did two field
experiments in 2017-18 we generated
molecular markers by using genotype by
sequencing we ran QTL mapping using all
of the above data and then I did the
best I could to translate that knowledge
that we gained in compare and contrast
it with all of the other really great
research that people are doing so the
canonical way of making a by parental
mapping population is to cross parent a
with parent B and then begin to
consecutively self this f1 hybrid each
time you increase the homozygosity of
those lines and by 8 rounds of selfing
you get over 99% homozygous lions I do
not want to spend eight years in grad
school if possible luckily there is a
really amazing shortcut called double
haploid technology and this is a this is
this is a can of worms unto itself but
in a nutshell you can produce 100%
homozygous lines and essentially one
step the way you do so is you take
pollen which exists in a haploid stage
and you do induce it to double to make a
double haploid and then you use a tissue
process culture to recover plantlets
that
a double haploid genotype so in this
case I croc we are our group that wrote
this paper produce double haploid
population using a cross between this
Chinese kale and a broccoli not not a
beautiful broccoli but a broccoli
nonetheless and we produce over 200
double haploid lines that are really all
over the map for this heading Walley
characteristics right as well as a lot
of other traits we grew them out
beforehand and got a sense on how they
were similar and different and use that
information to determine the traits that
we wanted to characterize in this
population so everything from the size
of the flower buds to the shape of the
head uniformity of the flower buds we
looked at some leaf morphology
characteristics some plants had very
pointy leaves some plants had very
serrated leaf margins for example not
necessarily important for broccoli but
for developing novel leafy greens
classes this could be useful information
why not grab it
bud morphology traits some had yellow
flowers some had white the shape of the
bud might seem a little trivial but
multiply that over many different buds
and it has pretty large consequences on
the ultimate shape of the head and then
had uniformity trades head extension etc
this is these are histograms of all of
the phenotype data that I collected and
typically see a normal distribution
which is what you would expect under
complex control multiple genes lead to
more quantitative results however flower
color we saw a very binary response
where the flowers were either yellow or
white so strong evidence of single gene
control what was strange however growing
this in the field is about seven
five percent of lines had white flowers
and 25% had yellow flowers and a double
haploid population you would expect a
one to one segregation ratio for a
single gene so that was very difficult
to get our mind around at the time but
hold that in your mind for a minute a
consequence of this eastern broccoli
project where we've thought a lot about
quality and horticultural crops is is
how to quantify it that particular
quality so there's a statistical
technique called relative importance
analysis that allows you to evaluate
something like overall quality one to
ten how beautiful is a head of broccoli
in terms of all of these other traits
and this technique allows you to
consider both the contribution of a
trait like head size or shape
independently and in conjunction with
all of the other traits so I ran this
analysis and unsurprisingly I found that
head uniformity compactness head shape
and the bracketing explains most of the
horticultural quality we wrote a paper
about this where we made a bunch of
people look at the same field of
broccoli and sort of parsed out biases
that people have when thinking about
broccoli and I and some collaborators
made this into an R package if you'd
like to try it with your horticultural
crop feel free to do so
genotyping followed a pretty canonical
technique we grew the plants in a
greenhouse extracted DNA digested that
DNA with a restriction enzyme ligated
with a barcode I sent it off for
sequencing got back 35 gigabytes of data
and found about 168 million high quality
reads and there that data got pumped
into the tasseled GBS pipeline I was
very lucky that the best Brassica
oleracea reference genome is in fact the
Chinese kale parent that
this population was made from so I was
able to align those reeds to that
reference genome and get really nice
results due to that similarity I found
about a two hundred and sixty four
thousand snips after running this
pipeline I wanted to whittle this down
to the most informative most high
quality snips here you see these sort of
changes are likely recombination events
that happened during the generation so
there's a lot of redundant information
that doesn't need to be kept so how do
you choose the best marker for any given
recombination event that's where I spent
a lot of time this is the genotypes of
all 200 lines as I was getting close to
the end these are these columns are the
nine chromosomes of Brassica oleracea
and each row is one of the double
haploid lines and purple means it got
the allele from the chinese kale parent
and green means it got the allele from
the broccoli parent there are some kind
of weird glitches in here which turns
out to be alignment errors so I've spent
a lot of time trying to clean this out
like seeing if this particular marker
was aligned to the wrong place in the
genome discarding it or in some cases I
was able to correctly assign it to its
true location so this is the
recombination frequency across all nine
chromosomes or linkage groups at this
point but whatever this is the genetic
map that I made on the Left I've plotted
in terms of marker density and on the
right this is just simply all of the
markers in terms of recombination
frequency here you see some regions have
much higher marker density than others
these lower density regions typically
correspond with centromeric regions
where less recombination is happening
um what we were able to show though is
for virtually every recombination event
we were able to find one marker so we
are pretty happy being able to basically
get all of the information we possibly
could out of this out of this population
you would expect a one to one
segregation distortion where half of the
plants got the allele from the broccoli
half got it from the Chinese kale and
I've plotted across each chromosome how
this segregation works and usually the
results were pretty close to this
one-to-one segregation pattern we know
it if certain regions were pretty
significantly skewed in some cases
three-to-one segregation Distortion keep
that in fact in your mind for a minute
as well I followed I used a technique
called multiple QTL mapping which is
really sort of an algorithm that helps
you control for false discovery rates it
protects against overfitting there's a
tendency to just keep adding more and
more QTL and explaining more of the
variance than your model which is not
correct also this technique protects
against QTL that are in coupling or
repulsion fees I'm gonna show a lot of a
number of these QTL plots this is the
QTL peak showing the logarithm of odd
scores which has essentially the
strength of association between the
genotype and the phenotype this is a 95%
significant threshold that's estimated
from thousand bootstrap replications
where I shuffle the phenotypic data and
run the analysis over and over again
what's the odds of finding a peak given
spurious data essentially and then at
the bottom we have these 9 chromosomes
where I've aligned each marker
underneath these are all 56 QTL for the
25 traits that I looked up
I also spend a lot of time trying to
leverage all of the work done with other
Brassica crops and a rabid abscess works
so what I did is I made a clunky script
that works that would estimate the 95%
confidence interval and mega base pairs
where a QTL began and ended and then I
use that to extract genes from the
Brassica oleracea genome annotation and
then I ran that through a pipeline where
it compared those genes against genes
found in the online resource tear and
ensembl plants and that allowed me to
conduct homology searches of different
Brassica species or rabid OPS's which
was really useful so flower color is not
an important horticultural quality trait
per se but we know it's single diene
control so I included it and I found one
QTL that was located on the end of
chromosome 3 I'm going to include some
of these 2 dimensional plots as well and
this shows epistatic interactions
between genomic regions so if we saw a
yellow spot here there would be an
interaction between chromosome 2 and a
we did not find evidence of Epis tacit
the any epistatic interactions and for
this trait paper recently came out where
this group mapped this carotenoid
degradation gene CCD for two chromosome
three at about 56 mega bases on that
chromosome which is this exact location
so that was a really nice proof of
concept that this pipeline was working
right we were able to reproduce this
finding
also this region of the genome
corresponds to strong segregation
distortion where 75% of the lines got
the allele from the Chinese kale parent
which has white flowers so that makes
perfect sense to explain that
three-to-one segregation pattern which
was great to see leaf wax eNOS has a
pretty big implication on insect damage
and sack resistance our populations
segregated for this we found one QTL on
chromosome 9 with some evidence of an a
static interaction with other locations
a really nice paper came out recently
that described expression patterns of
different wax biosynthesis genes in
broccoli and they identified a number of
candidates that could be implicated Iran
identified those genes and the
annotation and compared and contrasted
that with my QTL mapping results and I
found this mah one gene co-located with
my the peak of my QTL which is pretty
neat in fact I found five very similar
copies of it there as well and so again
it's important to note that this is not
proof it's just providing additional
supporting evidence for future work this
sepal tip is this is a really common
defect that's seeing in eastern broccoli
varieties this is problematic seems to
be somewhat genotype specific i within
this population i found a single QTL for
that tree on chromosome 1 there is a
paper that was studying some different
Brassica species that found what appears
to be a fairly similar phenotype for
that problem and they
said they showed that this gene ap2 was
likely involved and turns out that I
found an AP to copy very close to this
QTL peak leaf margin in terms of
breeding leafy Brassica greens this
could be a useful trait to have there's
two two papers I found that study
Brassica leaf margin one found this late
meristem identity gene and another found
this lobe leafed gene within my analysis
this LMI jeene ko segregated with this
QTL peak I didn't find evidence of this
ll gene in my analysis and that I'm not
saying this this result is wrong it's
that genetic variant doesn't seem to be
present within this mapping population
this is sort of an overhead view of
those 56 QTL I found arranged in a
similar way so the vertical bar is the
peak and then the horizontal is the 95%
confidence interval there are certain
regions that seem to be pretty important
I'm calling these hotspots where I found
the same QTL appearing for multiple
traits and this one was the most
interesting HQ 9 hotspot where these
pink which are horticultural quality
traits and yellow which is days to from
transplant to flood pardon me
days from transplanting to flowering and
days from transplant to head maturity so
this something interesting is happening
here this region of the Brassica
oleracea genome is synthetic with a
rabid OPS's chromosome 5 which contains
a number of important flowering genes I
did some previous work where I compared
Brassica
pardon me broccoli landraces on a less
improved varieties against modern f1
hybrids and I studied the amount of
linkage disequilibrium so differences
between this green and this purple line
are evidence of selection for that
particular genomic region so on
chromosome 9 was especially interesting
and I found these several hot spots
where the modern hybrids have enriched
linkage disequilibrium compared to the
land races and in fact this this region
about 50 megabase pairs on chromosome 9
seems to be an example of that so
there's evidence that humans have been
inadvertently selecting for whatever
allele is present there another paper
that I was part of studied heat
tolerance in broccoli and found a QTL in
the same region on chromosome 9 another
really nice paper studied curd
initiation and cauliflower under heat
stress and they found QTL and this
gentleman region as well so odds are
something important is happening here
some questions I had about this broccoli
heading phenotype is it a single gene
that controls it is that there are there
many genes is it a complex control if it
is complex
is it a conditional thing where you need
the presence of many different genes or
is there a small number of genes that
control a larger number of traits those
are some questions that I had this is an
example of pleiotropic control where one
gene is having creating implications for
multiple other traits so this is the QTL
mapping I did on head formation in
broccoli and I found for QTL one of them
was
is much larger than the other than the
others
and then this peak corresponds with that
head quality 9 hotspot that provides
evidence of complex control this is not
as five minutes okay sorry let me get to
the end and we found evidence of
epistatic interactions as well where
chromosome 9 is interacting with other
genomic regions pleiotropic control this
same hotspot has consequences for these
other traits head color are the head
compactness uniformity acting so we can
rule out the single gene hypothesis and
show that there's probably strongly
atrophic control in this heading
phenotype we found the FLC gene was
located under that head quality 9 peak
and in a nutshell we found 56 QTL 10
regions that seemed to be important for
high quality broccoli we are able to
produce a really nice set of markers
that other researchers can use when
studying this population we were able to
explain this broccoli heading phenotype
over 80% of model variants we found
support for this flc1
the role of flc1 in this heading and
flowering time and we showed that a
pleiotropic model is probably very
likely Thomas and Mark were co-authors
on the paper and our great mark Farnum
made the double haploids Miranda and
alia helped me a lot with the field work
Roberto
Dennis John Jacob Landis and Sandra all
read the manuscript and gave me some
really nice feedback and the University
of Wisconsin DNA sequencing facility
did the sequencing so any questions I
[Applause]
answered everything that's all there is
to know about broccoli just kidding
yes sir I'm a little bit I'm sure of
this question but I'll ask it anyway
so there was one paper you or a
co-author do a temper
yes so what I'm wondering is is it
involved in the temperature that that's
great question
that is a question that we're trying to
answer with some follow-up research
where we're growing heat sensitive and
heat tolerant broccolis under hot and
cold conditions and doing RNA seek
analysis so we it's very likely that
this population experienced heat stress
in the field trials we know that FLC is
very important in the vernalization
process it suppresses downstream
flowering time genes but the the exact
role that it plays is still to my
knowledge ambiguous does that answer
your question or you know when you save
fertilization so no is it a matter of
whether it's a really cold versus
getting modestly warm oh right right
what are the actual temperatures so
similar to crops like apple and grape
Brassica
have vernalization requirements to
flower with broccoli we know that that
threshold is actually relatively high so
it begins to accumulate chilling hours
below about 65 degrees Fahrenheit there
is variation and how it will help many
chilling hours it needs to ahead amongst
broccoli varieties but yeah so it's it's
a relatively high threshold that you
need time below to form a head yes I did
not spend a whole lot of time with that
question I know that's directly in your
wheelhouse yeah III don't know I you
know I was trying to wrangle 35
gigabytes of data and speak to the
literature what I could find but super
interesting question I I don't know the
answer to it here's the future for these
QTL and like with Cyril integration and
bringing programs I'm sure I think from
a on abstract level just simply knowing
more about why broccoli does its thing
is helpful understanding the
vernalization requirements and how that
can be modulated can be very useful to
breed more locally adapted broccoli
varieties potentially stacking various
sources of heat resistance into a
variety could be helpful also I don't
know maybe if someone
to just mix up all of the Brassica
oleracea vegetable types and to new
combinations it might be nice to uh you
know have a map on how did you sell just
hypothetically if someone had that idea
any other questions that I can and
perfectly or not answer yes sir that's
that's you want answer that one Thomas
no I don't know it could be just that
California is producing last suta water
stress drought different economic
factors but I know there was some big
price spikes that happened around that
time as well so maybe it was less
attractive to consumers I don't know
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu